patricia vécu treize ans avec une femme
au bout de cinq ans de vie commune
elles ont fait le choix d'enfants portés
par sa compagne patricia qui témoignent
à visage couvert à tous suivi les rendez
vous avec les médecins les psychologues
le gynécologue les inséminations en
belgique jusqu'à l'accouchement de leur
histoire de vie sont nées deux filles
âgées aujourd'hui de trois ans et demi
et 7 ans
depuis janvier 2011 patricia est séparée
et aux yeux de la loi elle n'a pas
d'existence légale alors au départ on
voulait faire une charte
et puis cette charte la faire valider
devant un juge après avec la vie
courante on l'a pas fait on a été
consulté un avocat pour faire une
délégation d'autorité parentale partiel
on a commencé et puis on a arrêté on a
arrêté en cours de route parce qu'à
versailles c'était c'était des refus
catégoriques au tribunal donc on n'avait
rien fait au moment de la séparation et
on s'était toujours dit que s'ils
avaient séparation on ferait une garde
alternée ou on s'arrangerait pour faire
une garde pour que
pour que j'aie les enfants c'est ce qui
s'est fait au début au bout de six mois
la changer d'avis on a fait un week-end
sur deux et puis le mardi soir
et au bout de six mois encore elle a
changé d'avis et là elle m'a dit tu les
verras une heure par semaine
tu n'as aucun droit tu n'es rien tu les
verras une heure par semaine le dimanche
quand ça m'arrange ses deux filles ne
sont plus venus dans la maison d'orgeval
depuis le mois de juillet dernier dans
leur chambre
rien n'a bougé comme un temps suspendue
à la douleur ici c'est la chambre de la
grande c'est la chambre qu'elle avait
quand elle était toute petite
il ya tous les doudous de cantal et et
quand elle est née mais c'est vrai que
temps en temps je rentre dans la chambre
dans les placards ya les vêtements il ya
tous les atouts les jouer et je me suis
effondrée plusieurs points ce qui la
fait tenir la procédure juridique
qu'elle a lancée pour obtenir un droit
de visite et d'hébergement
une première audience a eu lieu le 3
décembre le magistrat doit rendre son
avis le 21 janvier
patricia espère que le mariage pour tous
s'il est adopté
prévoir à l'autorité parentale délégués
ou conjointe
le vrai débat c'est pas le mariage décès
pas que le mariage c'est les enfants et
tout le monde le sait que c'est le vrai
débat c'est l'adoption des enfants
je pense que on est très en retard par
rapport à d'autres pays
quand je vois la hollande où c'est
commun chez eux et depuis quelques
années
l'espagne où ils ont admis l'adoption
l'espagne est un pays latin
pays latins et catholique et que je vois
le retard qu'a la france
je trouve pas qu'on feint vision
positive est difficile à avoir